- Lou Young here. Took another
L this week, two weeks in a row, man.
Uh, I thought I made some changes,
but I didn't. For that punishment,
I gotta go get some things, put it
in a little blender.
See what we can do.
Put five on it.
Faygo with the cotton candy.
Low fat. Working on my diet.
This is pretty good for your health.
Prepare to chef it up.
An episode of Chef Shlou.
Go ahead and start with our
cottage cheese.
Kind of give us a base layer.
Ah, f--k.
Now let's get our Slim Jims on.
And we snap, and we break.
Now we add a little
Faygo of the peach.
Every good chef should taste.
Drip. Drop. And a drip.
Gonna add the cotton candy.
A twang of cotton candy.
A shot.
And now... it is time.
I dunno about this. What the f--k?
Hell no.